I know what you're thinking cool ass
[ __ ] shirt David
kawaii Kanye [ __ ] yeah before we
start this video there's been a little
bit of confusion
okay the the podcast is still going
genius brain is still going every
Thursday and Sunday so yeah come on man
come on Kanye hey what is it going on as
you through the kiss a kiss you think
your mother
as promised yeah cute emic booties I
told you guys if you send me articles
you send me videos you send me some
crazy [ __ ] to talk about advice whatever
that I would do these og videos because
you're making my life easier with it
I don't got time to do all the research
and you know scribble Scrabble through
the squirrels crap what the [ __ ] is that
even award to basically filter through
all of the inert Irwin's ax I'm [ __ ]
on my words today man to basically
filter through all the interwebs to find
great stuff to talk about so you guys
have been helping me by emailing me and
sending me some funny-ass [ __ ] well
without further ado let's talk about it
first up this [ __ ] a wreath a Louisiana
student-athlete made national headlines
this month not for his performance on
the football field before his unique
name the coldest to ever do it Crawford
okay there's really not much the
distillery other than the fact that this
dude got the dopest name on earth this
[ __ ] is so funny to me because I swear
on baby Jesus six pound 12 ounces in 32
days old I could have sworn this is a
key and Peele sketch scores for loss of
Raptor Malloy's South Dakota State
University you want to talk about a
positive hood name I would love for
somebody to top this one against my son
the biggest ball sack you ever seen
Johnson you have to realize the parents
took a [ __ ] chance to name
their kid something this pathetic cuz
that means the moment this child shot
out of a [ __ ] his parents took a look
at his cute little face and said this
[ __ ] right here he gonna be
Dakotas to ever do it
and that's what we should name him all
right I guess love it I mean could you
imagine what did they put this child in
football and he [ __ ] suck or even
worse what would have happened if he
really was the coldest to ever do it but
he was just really good at kidnapping
children you said your son was gonna be
Dakotas to ever do it he is you know
just the coldest devis still a bunch of
babies that's all I think the most
fucked-up thing about the initial
statement in the article is the fact
that they said he's not really known for
his football
he's just numbers name next up we have a
man in st. Louis that is known to really
be the coldest man on earth listen man
I've seen a lot of crazy [ __ ] of my life
and I gotta tell you this one right here
this one this one this one young man in
the previous article if you really think
you dakotas to ever do it you ain't [ __ ]
compared to this guy during an armed
robbery a man with the rifle tries to
rob a man at a bar but the man was
unfazed listen if you haven't seen this
video
I'm just saying unfazed I'm talking
about the robber put a rifle to the
man's rib he reached over to steal his
phone and this dude said Johanns off my
goddamn phone I ain't got no unlimited
data huh this [ __ ] Cricket Wireless the
only place I got reception hello see
most people when it comes to these type
of dangerous situations they act like
they know exactly what they're going to
do specifically if your guy by nature
you like the front yeah well [ __ ] go to
my face I put I'll put up the Glock be
like they're not karate chop the
[ __ ] then the gun fall out of
hand and I hit him in the eye and the
Beretta fall out like deer but in
reality you ain't gonna do [ __ ] [ __ ]
you just like me if a man put a rifle to
my rib at a bar you best believe I will
be giving him everything in my pocket
and [ __ ] that he didn't even ask for ah
nobody knows what they're gonna do in a
situation like that unless they've been
in that situation period end of story
I used to tell myself when I was younger
if I ever saw somebody get robbed in
front of me I was gonna step in I was
gonna be like halt not today sir you
know what happened I saw somebody get
robbed in front of a Jamba Juice I
robbed that person with them
I'm gonna do [ __ ] just like me except
for this one guy that work at an office
depot this dude look like an assistant
manager that works at an Applebee's but
has seen some [ __ ] sir you are either
tough as nails or some woman broke your
spirit because there is no way in hell a
sane human being would have done that
but guys luckily for us I made a few
phone calls and I actually received the
audio footage of what he was saying
during that robbery
yeah yeah that is a titty well hello
okay who's this I think you might be a
gun Oh Miley Cyrus dropped another [ __ ]
pic look at that
pastrami pastrami yep
what no okay no that's not your fault
that's my phone
get your hands off me sir dumbass boy
with your stupid ass gone you ain't
gonna do [ __ ] but you got a big gun yeah
big boy oh oh you think I'm scared Oh
suck my dick [ __ ] you give a [ __ ] last
look you gonna take everything that you
have like my ex-wife did she took my
virginity I my dignity sucks huh well
that's it for the articles today if you
guys want me to do some more [ __ ] like
this 70 some more stuff and we'll get it
poppin until then I'll see y'all next
time
boom boom boom boom Beth I don't know
how many of these videos I will be doing
per week there are no promises but
remember hit the notification button and
make sure you guys are ready to see this
stuff hit up the email so you guys can
offer your articles and ask questions
that we will answer it on the podcast or
one of these videos my friends remember
genius brain podcast is still going
every Thursday and every Sunday make
sure you like comment subscribe and
share these videos because it's very
important I'm trying to get back in on
this YouTube game I miss y'all very much
love you very much see you at genius
brain baby
yeah